Vivek ramaswamy I think his net worth is
around half a billion or whatever he not
not only starts a a venture capital firm
to compete with ESG to oppose it he's
trying to run for president I'm like
this guy's outright like I'm gonna put
like Elon Musk we're going to throw it
off respect to him and he's a fighter I
love it I vote for him I'd vote for him
100 little joke like he is a better
version of Andrew Yang okay I agree yeah
he's on steroids he's on stairs he's
injury hanging on steroids yeah like you
know how Andrew Young I'm an
entrepreneur like how big was your
business have you had an exit but I'm an
entrepreneur we're like okay cool that's
great this guy's made money how did you
make your money what did you do all this
stuff vivek's like no I build a
multi-billion dollar you know and here's
where I'm at right now and he writes the
books and he goes out there and by the
way
do you see how fast his Twitter and his
audience is growing do you see how many
people are looking at this guy saying
damn this guy is great at explaining it
you know he's great at breaking things
down he's he's one of the guys that
during this season every time there's a
run a new Star is Born I think this guy
is a star being born just a few months
ago he had 40 000 followers on Twitter
you know you know what the story is
he's working at he's building this
multi-billion dollar bio biotech company
the BLM riots happen
they come to him and say hey you should
put out a statement or you know change
your profile picture or whatever and
he's like oh okay yeah for sure because
he's like whatever and he puts out the
statement where he it's very neutral uh
we should come together and you know put
an end of the violence and we're all
Americans here apparently they came to
him and said that was inadequate it was
it was it was bad and then within a
month he had board members resign I'm
probably ruining the story to a certain
Rich he told me the story and so I'm a
Matt here's my vision of Vivek ramaswamy
he's just he's an entrepreneur he just
wants to start a business he wants to
create something of benefit he wants to
help Mankind and then he starts getting
beaten over the head by this woke ESG
corporate garbage that costs his
business money and friends and he didn't
even do anything he actually agreed with
them but not enough I think what they
did was they went to a guy of tremendous
intellect means and capability insulted
him and spat in his face and then he
just wiped it off and said you've
declared war I love what he's doing yes
by the way you know whether he does
anything in this one or not I hope he
doesn't go away me too uh he he is the
kind of guy that the opposition doesn't
want to debate because he's super
brilliant sharp history and made money
and as an entrepreneur and he's got a
background immigrant family story all of
that the profile is a is an anomaly okay
and he knows how to deliver the message
properly hopefully he gets more
attention and and not just that
he's uh I had him on my show called the
culture War podcast which is a new
Friday show I'm doing and he's sitting
there and he goes you know what I
probably shouldn't say this I'm gonna
get in trouble there's got to be some
Civic requirement for voting and he
talks about various ideas
um one of the ideas that we like to talk
about is service guarantee citizenship
it's an idea that is a reference to
Starship Troopers in this story if you
want to vote you have to give two years
of service to the community in some
fashion either it's it's not necessarily
military service it could be you know
working in a library or something don't
get Pat started on who he thinks should
vote but so uh one of the ideas that
Vivek brings up is uh maybe when you
when when you fill out your Selective
Service card you get a voter ID and that
is the bare minimum requirement you you
fill this out you don't have to fill it
out you could you could say you know I'm
not going to sign up for Selective
Service and men or women are both
required to but when you do now you can
vote there's got to be some standard I'm
like that's a particularly Brave thing
to say yeah if you genuinely believe
yeah I think when he was talking to me
in an open format just what do you want
to do why want to do it it felt real it
felt genuine I could feel the emotion of
I'm like they they they figuratively
spat on this guy who who and now he said
then I I will return fire I will go to
war with you and he's speaking about
what he genuinely thinks and believes
I told him this I said look I don't
think you're gonna win yeah but I do
think you're going to make the
conversation better and I do think
you're going to positively uh change
this country by standing up on a debate
stage saying everything you just said
and making DeSantis or Trump answer to
it do you think it's so funny you're
saying I was just going to say that but
do you think he'll make it on the stage
let's get into that part but it's funny
you're saying this I did this video in
2014 April 15 2014. Rob if you can pull
it up on uh YouTube to show it to him
and I broke it down and so many people
were pissed about this video was a video
titled earn the right to vote okay uh
earned the right to vote and everything
was about you I don't care if you're 40
years old 20 years old or 14 years old I
think a guy that's 14 years old that's
paying tax we don't need to play the
video I'm not going to do this here nice
Jersey I don't care if you're 14 years
old and you're
paying taxes you have more right to vote
than a 26 year old staying at home who's
never paid taxes you can vote so became
you have to pay a minimum of amount of
taxes to have the right to vote I like
that you know and then if you did a few
things your vote is actually two votes
meaning wow if you serve the military
you get an additional vote if you do
this so the more you contribute to
society I love that the more of a voice
you have the less you contribute to
society the more matter of fact if we
ever ran a country you know what our tax
system would be it'd be Progressive
except the other way around oh really
you know what that means you know what
it means Progressive the other way
around here
the more you contribute the less you pay
because I'm thankful for you we're
thankful for you but the less you use
your talents to contribute to society
the more taxes you pay so the people
that don't use their god-given talents
get taxed at the highest level the
people that contribute their god-given
talents and go above and beyond you get
taxed the least because you're making
our life easier because you're creating
jobs for everybody so vivex thinking if
that's what you said he was telling you
about voting you know all that stuff
he's going to piss a lot of people off I
love it but I love it I keep lighting it
up but that's what I respect I'm like
for a politician or someone who's
running to come out and be like there's
got to be some kind of Civic requirement
that shows a lot of honesty so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]